مشاهدينا المتابعه لعمليات الانقاذ في
حالات الزلازل يلحظ اعتمادا فرق الانقاذ
المختصه اليات محدده وتحضيرات يسبقها
تنسيق بين الفرق اهميه التنسيق تكمن في
توزيع الفرق على المناطق حسب الحاجه وحسب
حجم الاضرار ثم
تبدا وتشمل
ان يكون
اذا يوجد احتمالات لان يعلق النجون تحت
السلالم مثلا او تحت المكاتب ثم يلجا فريق
الانقاذ الى البحث عن الاصوات الضعيفه
وعلامات الحياه باستخدام معدات خاصه ومن
المعتاد ان يضرب عامل الانقاذ ثلاثه ضربات
متتاليه املا بان يرد احد من تحت الانقاض
كما تستخدم
مجسات اكسيد الكربون للبحث عن الناجين
اضافه الى الكاميرات الحراريه والكلاب
التي تعد فعاله جدا في مثل هذه الحالات
عمليه ازاله الانقاض تتطلب تامين
استقرارها اولا كان يوضع مثلث خشبي لتجنب
الانهيارات ومن ثم استخدام الرافعات او
الروافع الهيدروليكيه والحفارات
تحديد زمن انهاء عمليات الانقاذ يكون
بالتنسيق بين الفرق على الارض والسلطات
المعنيه ويحدث بين خمسه الى سته ايام في
المتوسط